hi I'm Sir John I'm here with glamour UK
and we're doing or beautiful looks and
taking you from zero to hero nine wine
day time to disco so I hope you guys
like so I'm gonna go now directly to
skin what we want to do is we want to
magnify the skin so I'm gonna use a
foundation and fallible fresh where it's
not heavy it's not going to congest your
pores it doesn't look like makeup it
looks like skin that's the goal the goal
is to look sexy almost like you woke up
looking like this so if you noticed in
terms of application method I'm using an
egg sponge
I love these babies because you're not
pouring all of your money into the
sponge
they're designed to actually give you
back your product on the skin so I put
this put some water in this a squeeze it
out so this is not completely soaking
wet and then I'm stippling so I see the
product on the back of my hand using a
very minimal amount and we're gonna go
in here and we're stippling so when
you're choosing a foundation the best
place to look for is your jaw and your
forehead your forehead picks up Sun the
fastest and your jaw is a really great
indicator of what your true complexion
is if you have a red skin use something
that's a yellow or an olive complexion
or a yellow tone to neutralize out the
warmth and if you happen to be too olive
it's okay to go with a warmer foundation
to neutralize out who you are what we're
going to do now we're gonna go directly
in the concealer so when on say
concealing I don't necessarily mean go
all the way up to your eyeliner that's
or your mascara line that's not what you
want to do so if you take a look if we
go in and and we go all the way up to
the lash line if you start to conceal it
looks like she starts to look tired and
sleepy we're not gonna do that I'm gonna
go directly up to the eyes but I'm gonna
stop maybe a millimeter away from the
lash line I'm taking this huge dopa
applicator on this brand new amazing
concealer called more than by infallible
L'Oreal Paris or dotting here ladies
this is the most concealer you need if
you need to conceal more than this I
want to have a conversation with you
about where your life is going this
brush right here is an eye shadow brush
allows the concealer to look just to
dissipate it looks like it's airbrushed
on it's okay to take your fingers and
warm it up only using the ring finger so
your index finger is too strong if
you're putting your eye cream on or your
concealer on every day with your index
you're gonna add yourself I love the
skin underneath everyone's eyes and it
always changes as we get older it moves
in the ships it has a mind of its own
concealer doesn't belong here so
whenever you're looking for a powder you
want to see does it drop or does it sort
of cascade into the air
if the Cascais into the air it's a
really lightweight formula but happens
to drop immediately it's too heavy for
your eye area so right now we're gonna
go in only in the t-zone you don't need
more powder than me I love this product
this is called early beauty elixir
it's smoothing it allows your skin to
glow but I love this as a prep
foundation but not only the prep around
nation I'm gonna go in and give it a
beautiful luster to the body into the
face with this as well the way I like to
highlight is there's a strategic area
that you want to glow and you don't want
to glow in the wrong area and I'm gonna
show you exactly how to do that right
now so these are Glo drops and they
happen to be by L'Oreal Paris but I like
to use them and layer my glowy products
so it's all about layering ladies use
that to go right on the sides of the
face you can see that anything that
glows we want to stop when it gets to
the eyes I want to make sure that all of
her shimmery blushes or shimmery
highlights stop there and the reason is
is because underneath the eyes on the
first and the front of your cheeks is
where it looks unflattering it so I'm
also gonna debunk a huge myth right now
so pay attention and remember I said it
here first you do you want to glow on
the nose but you want to only glow
between the eyes so now we're going to
make this a bit more bronze so that
bronze element is gonna make it really
3-dimensional so I'm using a foundation
a little bit deeper just to lay the
groundwork and then we're gonna set it
with a matte powder a little bit in the
temples as well don't be afraid to work
this into your hairline a little bit
underneath the jawline
okay so I'm gonna show you guys the
three second nose contour so any good
nose contour starts in the sockets of
the eyes so what we're gonna do I'm
going to go directly in the socket of
the eye and I want it to go directly
along the side of the nose underneath
the tip and then go up the side and I'm
gonna finish in the sockets or the
hollow of her pilot so now we're going
to go into bronzer bronzer is gonna be
the thing the icing on the cake is like
the bippity-boppity-boo know why we love
this color is because it is not
orange is always an olive undertone in
ladies if you make a mistake or if you
feel like your bronzer or your cheek has
gone down too far you want to lift your
cheeks a bit break out your foundation
sponge that you have on your vanity or
your sink and lift her scope again this
is like your magic eraser I want to give
her a bit of a golden need more gold we
like to call this here a glamour
24-karat magic and so it's all about
that gold gilded light reflection what
we're gonna do now we're gonna go into a
little bit of a lip so you see this
palette I don't want to go to the one
that has the most color we're gonna go
for something sheer and if you look at
this outfit I want to I want to match
the life that she's in already so ladies
I'm brushing this on and there's a new
trend around a diffused line at the edge
of the lips and you can only do that
with a brush so if you notice if you
take a look I mean I'm brushing the
edges I'm gonna take a little bit of
this clip color I'm gonna warm up the
cheeks just a little don't tell me your
grandmother has never done this before
that's it
[Music]
so now we've gone from skin to a
beautiful glow and bronzing the
complexion and I think now it's time to
go for a punch of color so we're gonna
go for a blue liner like a denim you
know turquoise inspired liner a feel on
line I love this liner so much this is
all I have left of it it's liner is
called cobalt by L'Oreal Paris I'm gonna
go directly into the waterline and so if
there are any makeup artists out there
and never you have a client and you're
doing liner our lashes and their eyes
start to water I'm gonna give you a tip
so take your hand l and cover your mouth
carry them off and so wag your tongue
all the way around wag your tongue all
the way around all the way around so you
can't produce tears and wagging tongue
around the same side but I don't want to
stop here I want to have a little bit
more fun so if you notice I only placed
the royal blue in the center underneath
the pupils someone have some fun in
different areas of the eyes with
different color liners why not I'm not
sure if you guys can see that blend you
see that multi-facet how prismatic that
is that wave color that's what we want
and if you notice I'm going to take this
if you guys are really close we're
taking any excess and I'm going to pull
see that pull right there a little
action is my training will where I want
my winged stand this is what I like to
call under-eye smudged
so under-eye smudge is just so modern
it's kind of rock star we're gonna go
for the liner on the top just a
beautiful blue so I'm gonna be I'm just
gonna be a little bit like extra pan I'm
gonna take even lighter blue and look
down from here and just make this even
more fun and play with even more color
and there you have it ladies and gents
this is wave liner
[Music]
okay everyone so now what we're gonna do
we're gonna go into really impactful
statement and I love statement eyes if
you guys know anything about the work
that I do own the people that I work
with I love eyes that have massive
massive impact so we're gonna go for it
so I'm taking this liner and I'm heavily
lining the top and the bottom
this amoliant pencil it's gonna give me
so much grab with my eye shadow so once
I blend this baby out it's going to give
it's gonna show every particle of
prismatic color in that beautiful eye
shadow that you spending so much money
on ladies so now I'm starting to just
take a stiff brush not a fluffy brush
I'm taking a stiff synthetic brush and
we're going in and we're blending so the
way to get really impactful eyes in my
opinion is to layer so you want to layer
your products you want to layer your
pencils the shadows possibly your
glitters blades if you notice I'm taking
a brush and really blending underneath
the eyes and this just creates a little
bit of immediate drama so we're using
eyeliner as an eyeshadow base so I'm
gonna take a hot pink shadow or hot pink
and blush and wrap it inside of decrease
of the eyes so ladies if you notice on
all of my work on anything I do I never
put eyeshadow on the brow bone as a
highlight it's over it's done it's
played out it's not cool anymore don't
do it I love red and purple together I
think it's beautiful it reminds me of
like cabaret so I'm using a short stiff
brush ladies when you're apply your
eyeshadow do not use a big fluffy brush
which you want it opt for is a brush
that's stiffer you have a bit more
control and this is going to deliver all
of your product directly onto your
eyelid so now we've deposited all of our
purple color which I love and I could
stop here but why stop here right so I'm
taking a little bit of this glitter and
guess where this color came from do you
guys remember Coachella this is the same
color that I used on Coachella both
nights but we're gonna take this and
we're gonna put this directly into the
tear duct and bring a little disco into
the daytime so we're gonna do a red
matte lip we're gonna line the lips with
red and then we're going to go on top of
the stain I think it's working so now
we're gonna deposit a bit of lipstick on
top of the liner just so it stays for a
long time so I'm using this color by
L'Oreal is called rue signature and this
color is called I represent and that's
it that's all I have for you guys I hope
you enjoyed me here
Kalama UK I mean she's ready to hit the
mark for more videos like this subscribe
and follow glamour UK
[Music]